Andy Richter here against my better  judgment we asked you to vote on what  issue my song of Buster's team should  tackle next and you made your decision  clear you're tired of Conan O'Brien  being the only person with a signature  dance move on our show and you want me  to have a dance that I can call my very  own thank you very much so I want to see  your videos of what you think the Andy  Richter signature dance move should be  act it out you know be original get  funky with your help we'll cut the cord  on Conan's cutesy string dance and  finally get a real dance move on late  night television  I'm Andy Richter thank you and good  night  [Music]